a coven 19 variant first detected in
india in october of 2020
has quickly spread around the world and
been detected in nearly 100 countries
within 10 months
as of july more than 80 percent of known
coveted cases in the u.s
are caused by the delta variant the
delta variant is currently the greatest
threat in the u.s
to our attempt to eliminate covet 19.
the delta variant is both more
transmissible
and possibly more severe studies have
shown that some coveted vaccines are
effective at preventing symptomatic
illnesses caused by the strain
nevertheless as of july cases are on the
rise in countries where a large part of
the population is vaccinated
even countries that have been previously
spared from the pandemic are now
battling a ferocious wave of infections
we look at some moments in key countries
to understand why the deadly outbreak of
delta
is not just threatening the economic
recovery but also the return to normal
around the world
first we go back to october of 2020.
health authorities say the delta variant
was first detected here
in the state of maharashtra in india
by the spring the number of cases in
india began ticking up
then from march to may infections jumped
20-fold plunging the country in disarray
it ripped through the country thousands
and thousands
of new infections every day hospitals
were completely overwhelmed and they
were running out of oxygen
for patients who needed help breathing
public health experts blamed india's
deadly wave on several factors
there were political rallies for state
elections that drew large crowds
there was also a religious festival in
april when millions of hindus gathered
to bathe in the ganges river
and then a few days later the government
relaxed safety measures like mass
squaring and social distancing
but scientists say what really helped
accelerate the caseload
was delta variants molecular composition
and its nine key mutations and the
protein spikes that surround the virus
mutations on these spikes allow the
various to invade human cells more
easily
making the delta variant about 50
percent more transmissible than others
by june 1st the variant wasn't only in
india but detected in more than 60
countries
and the united kingdom was one of the
first western countries to see an
alarming increase in cases
as delta became the dominant strain
we're seeing cases growing by about
64 per week and in the worst affected
areas
it's doubling every week what surprised
public health officials was that around
75 percent of the adult british
population had already received at least
one dose of a vaccine
and about 50 percent was fully
vaccinated the uk is a really
unfortunate situation
there are good levels of vaccination
there but
the variant took off anyway and that was
partly because vaccines were reacting
differently to delta than they had to
earlier strains
by mid-june studies showed that one dose
of some vaccines
was 17 percent less effective at
preventing symptomatic
illnesses caused by delta but two doses
provided good protection
the more the delta variant is allowed to
spread
the greater the risk of mutations which
would evade
the vaccines or evade treatments and
we'd kind of be almost back to the
beginning
by late june delta was detected in
countries that had been slower to
vaccinate
in part because they had been spared the
brunt of the pandemic and cases began
rising in these places
australia and thailand imposed lockdowns
even japan decided to ban spectators at
the olympics because of a new wave of
infections
there are many many many countries that
don't have access to vaccine yet
not many people in the population are
vaccinated and this is the huge concern
about this variant that is just going to
rip through these countries
meanwhile in the u.s as people headed
into their fourth of july weekend
the delta variant had become the
dominant strain people were traveling
again and many stopped wearing masks
after the cdc
said it wasn't necessary for those who
were fully vaccinated
the varian has mostly spread to areas
where vaccination rates have been slow
in some parts of the country like in los
angeles authorities have asked people to
wear masks in
indoor public places regardless of
vaccination status
but some public health experts say the
appetite for another lockdown
is low it's difficult to ask people
to once again adopt these measures the
message is
everybody needs to get vaccinated so on
july 4th biden urged people to do just
that
as the administration planned to make it
easier for people to get their shots
like sending more mobile clinics to
festivals and sporting events
while the virus hasn't been vanquished
we know this
it no longer controls our lives it no
longer paralyzes our nation
and it's within our power to make sure
it never does
again and that means it's a race against
time to vaccinate more people around the
world
before the coronavirus mutates again